I live in uncertainty every day every
time I look at myself in the clear and
cool waters of Africa I expect to see a
beautiful giraffe staring back at me but
all I see is a [ __ ] lover I was lost
without hope in this desolate world
why was Mother Earth so cruel as to not
grant me with the noscopes I so
desperately deserved and also for the
body of a giraffe hello my name is
Falcon Lord X X X X X hello hello my
name is Falcon Lord X X X capital X X X
X I am a trans species human to giraffe
the wide fields of Africa is where I
belong but yet why do I feel so lost I
think of the Falcon lovers of the world
and how they have taken me so far but
even I would only have three subs
instead of three thousand if it weren't
for him him pretty big the way he yells
into his microphone as he plays games
the way his golden hair falls like waves
of his sky-blue eyes it makes me want to
cry
Pierce's my senpai and I the kohai who
he will never notice I sigh in the
watering hole listening to the far-off
sounds of elephants and gazelles roaming
the sun-soaked blades the sounds of
Africa are so peaceful contradicting my
thunderstorm of feelings y1 views ever
noticed me yes he has made videos
acknowledging my existence but I was
nothing more than a laughingstock to him
a joke a falcon loser who would want
anything to do with me suddenly a loud
cry Pierce's my eardrums
who wants to do this I think isn't this
supposed to be you
oh I think it'd be fun if you try to be
me let's have a beauty off let's do this
all right okay you go first
are you working for the barrels all
right this is my money are you working
for the barrels all looks like you're
good Martin yeah buddy I blink familiar
voice the way the volume of the tone
almost gave me a freaking heart attack
could it be no I think shaking my head
it's definitely not this better increase
the noscopes I guess it is Peary play
immediately I stand and spin around
running towards the sand what I see
shocks me be surrounded by lions trying
to fight them off with his laptop damn
it you're fighting a lion
damn it kids cried after smacking one of
the Lions upside the head and seeing it
was unharmed
pity fight I cried I must save him i
spring into action brushing over and
making my breast raft call just hop in
there
Lions ears start bleeding and then run
away living Pierce in the grand I rush
to pierce and kneel before him hey Perry
pack I
a yellow Beauty pie I yell are you hurt
Peter pie groans [ __ ] Lord kids asked
yeah you saved me
I just couldn't let you tap it I cried
sparkly enemy tears falling from my face
I love you your smiles
I love you
suddenly we embrace and my one dream has
come true
[Music]